let's bring it back to a team where we
all thought was going to make Super Bowl
hopes
huh
it's hard to even talk about this
because Aaron Rodgers injury and who
Aaron Rodgers is and what it could have
meant for the Jets with Aaron Rodgers
and let me tell you why they should and
I know and we look on the sideline we
see the frustration with all the players
and especially with Garrett Wilson with
Zach Wilson and it gets a little toxic
sometimes you know
um when you got this between your best
wide receiver and your starting
quarterback
it hurts and we see it on I think
everyone saw them we saw it between
Jalen hurts and AJ Brown uh should we
should we over Panic no but we gotta
understand uh there's a lot of emotions
that come with football when you're
competing you want to be the best and
you know you're unguardable girl what's
this one of them guys who we can't sleep
on he's a top 10 top 15 receiver
um and he's a our you know offensive
rookie of the year so you know when he's
not getting the receptions and he's
getting held to a certain amount of
yards there's a lot of frustration and
and as deserves and I say we can't panic
because look and I'm a and this is the
truth okay all off season everyone's
been talking about Aaron Rodgers okay uh
you know coach Salah uh you know is a
great coach but guess what he's been
planning to have Aaron Rodgers that team
was getting built for Aaron Rodgers that
team wasn't getting built for Zach
Wilson Zach Wilson yes he was in
training camp but no one was expecting
him play he probably wasn't taking the
same reps getting the same looks getting
everything like Aaron Rodgers was and
that's just the reality and now they're
trying to adjust and limit the system
and come back to a new system because of
Zach Wilson and his inability this is
not and he's being compared to a Hall of
Famer which isn't fair
he had he needs time to grow he needs
time to learn
um y'all are forgetting that there's
only 32 starting jobs in the NFL
quarterback and he's one of them right
now if it was so easy a bunch of people
could be quarterback and I know there's
a lot of frustration for judge fans and
things like that but this isn't a walk
in the park job there's only 32 starting
jobs in the NFL for a reason uh
defensive ends you can be rotatable
there's two of them on East Side Corners
there's more quarterback is one of the
hardest positions in the NFL and you
expect a third year guy who got bench
last year said hey we're going to take
Aaron Rodgers his Focus might have been
there we don't know what his Focus his
mentor was like when the whole trade
thing was happening how the guys treated
him
and a lot goes into it and how much you
want to give to this team his team needs
to give back to him they need to pour
into him so he could be the guy they
want to be and if they can do that
um there's a bunch of free agent guys
um we saw earlier about Ryan said he
wouldn't take the job
um but you can't say Cam Newton and Joe
Flacco we truly just don't know I just
don't think there's
uh a guy right now that we can say that
could come in and just change the whole
system around and say hey this guy is
going to take us to the Super Bowl I I
don't think there is a guy out there
right now unless you trade for him and
he's a backup somewhere else
um that's going to make that impact and
get you what you want uh just Nation so
pour it to him uh help groom him grow
him and things like that but I think
everything's going to be okay once you
get back into it